most senate republicans joining
democrats to override president trump's
veto on friday the republican-led
chamber turned aside mr trump's veto of
a massive annual defense spending bill
the vote was overwhelming
81-13 this first override of the trump
presidency comes just weeks before he
leaves office
this morning the president does seem
more focused on next week's
congressional certification of the
election though hoping to overturn
president-elect joe biden's win
ouija jain is at the white house wija
good morning
good morning to you jeff and good
morning to everybody this veto override
marks a rare public rebuke
of president trump by members of his own
party and there are
other signs that his power over the gop
is cracking
as his time in the white house comes to
an end including in his
extraordinary challenge of the election
results which is going nowhere
the bill on reconsideration has passed
during an unusual
new year's day session the
republican-controlled senate voted to
override president trump's attempt to
block a 740
billion dollar defense policy bill we've
passed this legislation 59
years in a row and one way or another
we're going to complete the 60th annual
ndaa and pass it into law before this
congress concludes
on sunday the president wanted the
measure to include a repeal of some
legal protections for social media
companies
on twitter he said failing to do so was
pathetic
mr trump also promoted what he called
the big
protest to stop the steal his supporters
planned to gather
in washington on wednesday as congress
meets to certify
president-elect joe biden's victory late
last night a federal judge who was
appointed by
mr trump dismissed a lawsuit filed by
texas congressman louie gohmert
who argued falsely that vice president
mike pence has the power to decide the
outcome of the election germart also
said the congress is set for a showdown
on january
6 with over 140 house members pledging
to object to mr biden's claim of victory
missouri republican josh hawley is so
far the only senator who said he plans
to object to the certification of the
election results he's also standing by
president trump's push
to increase stimulus checks from 600 to
2 thousand dollars a person
taking a swipe at gop senate colleagues
who have
not offered support with all due respect
this doesn't seem to me to be a
republicans versus democrats issue this
seems to be the senate versus the united
states of america
in georgia two republican senators are
fighting to keep their seats in runoff
elections on tuesday
but senator david perdue is in
quarantine after someone on his campaign
tested
positive for kovit 19. it's terrible
timing but we are not going to
miss a step the georgia runoffs will
determine
control of the u.s senate last night
president trump tweeted that the races
are illegal and
invalid which is not true despite making
that false claim
both he and vice president pence plan to
campaign
on behalf of the republicans in georgia
on monday
the eve of election day dana weija thank
you